[Musique]
le centre de musique baroque de
versailles fait partie des élus la
fondation bettencourt schueller a sorti
le 25 février dernier un album viva 30
ans d'art choral qui célèbre 30 ans
d'engagement pour le chant choral elle a
sélectionné pour cela dix neuf extraits
d'enregistrements réalisés par des
choeurs qui ont tous reçu le prix
liliane bettencourt pour le chant choral
on est très très fiers d'avoir été
retenus parce qu'évidemment en trente
ans il y a eu plus de loreak c'est
mathématique que 19 c'est une
reconnaissance déjà d'avoir reçu ce prix
en 1997 est une nouvelle reconnaissance
pour le travail de mon prédécesseur pour
le travail du centre de musique baroque
qui beaucoup pour 900 chorale en france
l'extrait sélectionner une partie du
disque vêpres pour saint-louis consacré
au compositeur baroque marc antoine
charpentier sorti en 2004 par l'ensemble
de la maîtrise du cmbv est dirigée à
l'époque par olivier schmid
c'était une expérience assez magique
puisque c'est enregistre à la chapelle
royale du château de versailles de nuit
à l'époque parce que dans les toutes ces
églises on peut enregistrer que la nuit
cet après midi là ce sont les chantres
actuelle du cmbv qui ont repris des
extraits de ce disque notamment confites
et bord tibi dominé
[Musique]
la musique baroque reste un genre
musical indissociable de l'art choral la
musique baroque sans l'art choral c'est
comme un pain sans farine c'est pas
possible la musique chorale vous en avez
dans la musique sacrée il y a toujours
des choeurs très souvent des coeurs et à
l'opéra aussi dans les tragédies dans
tout ce qui était représentée sur la
scène de l'opéra il y avait des coeurs
et l'art chorale les choeurs font
vraiment partie de la musique baroque
c'est c'est un des indices de cette
musique là la directrice artistique de
l'album viva 30 ans d'art choral a été
confié à laurence equilbey directrice du
choeur de chambre accentue ce et d'
insulte à orchestra parmi les autres
ensembles musicaux présents dans l'album
les arts florissants de william christie
ou encore le concert spirituel d'hervé
niquet